we've already talked about how a benzene
ring is very let me draw a
better-looking benzene ring than that
that a benzene ring is very stable
because it's aromatic that these
electrons in these PI orbitals that form
these double bonds they're actually just
not in this double bond they can keep
swapping this one can go here this one
can go there that one can go there
actually they don't go back and forth
they actually just completely go around
the entire the entire ring and when a
molecule is aromatic it stabilizes it
but we've seen examples of aromatic or
actually in particular we've seen
examples of benzene rings that have
other things bumping off of them whether
they're halides or whether they're OAH
groups and what we want to do in this
video is think about how that might
happen how do things get added on to a
benzene ring so we're going to learn
about electrophilic aromatic
substitution let me write that down
electro electro philic electrophilic
aromatic aromatic substitution
substitution and you might say well Sal
you just said you're adding things to
the ring but the reality is is that
there's six hydrogen's here there's one
hydrogen two hydrogen's three hydrogen's
four hydrogens five hydrogen's and six
hydrogen's they're always there if you
don't draw them they are implicitly
there so we're actually doing when you
add a when you add a a chlorine or
bromine or an O age group it's actually
replacing one of these hydrogen's that's
why it is substitution its aromatic
because we're dealing with benzene ring
we're dealing with an aromatic molecule
and we're going to see that we need a
really strong electrophile in order to
do this so let's think about this at how
this will happen before I do that let me
just copy and paste this because I don't
wanna have to redraw this so let me just
copy it just like that so let's say we
have a really strong electrophile and
I'll give you particular cases in the
next few video so you can better
visualize what a really strong
electrophile is but just from the word
itself electrophile you could imagine
it's something that loves electrons it
wants electrons
really really really really really badly
and usually it has a positive charge
usually has a positive charge so it
wants electrons badly wants electrons
actually let me make it very clear
instead of saying wants electrons badly
because when you're talking about
electro files or nucleophiles you're
actually talking about how good
something is reacting you're not
actually talking about the actual
energies involved so let me put it a
different way good at getting electrons
good at getting electrons really really
really really really good at getting
electrons so what would happen what we
already said this is already pretty
stable these guys that can these
electrons these PI electrons can
circulate all around but if it's if we
if it gets if it bumps just in the right
way to something that's really good at
getting electrons what might happen what
might happen let's say we have this this
electron right here that the way we've
drawn it it's on this carbon right here
obviously the carbon is just at the
intersection I never drew the carbon but
if this electrophile which is really
good at getting electrons bumps in just
the right way this electron can go to
that electrophile that electron can go
to that electrophile and then would be
left with so let me copy and paste our
original molecule so then what would we
be left with so we no longer we no
longer have we no longer have this bond
right here we no longer have this bond
right here it has now been bonded to the
electrophile let me make it clear we had
this electron right here that electron
is still on this carbon right over here
at this intersection but the other end
of it the other electron has now been
given to the electrophile but think that
luck that's good at getting them so the
other side has been given to this
electrophile this electrophile now
gained an electron so it had a positive
charge now it will be neutral and once
again I'll show you a particular or
several particular cases of this in the
next few videos and let me just make it
clear so this bond this bond you can now
view it as being this bond now this
carbon right over here
this lost an electron so if it lost an
electron it will now have a positive
charge it will now have a positive
charge now this is hard to do
to a resonance stabilized molecule to a
benzene ring so that once again I said
I'm being a little bit repetitive this
has to be a very good electrophile to do
it but once this is there this is
actually a relatively stable carbo
cation and the reason why it is it's
only a secondary carbo cation but it's
actually a resident stabilized carbo
cation because this guy can go this
electron right here can be given to that
so this if this electron goes there then
it would look like this let me redraw it
I'll draw the resonance structures
quickly so you have your hydrogen you
have your electrophile that's what's not
electrophile any more but you have that
ease it's now been added you have that
hydrogen you have a double bond here let
me make that draw a little bit neater
you have this hydrogen you have this
hydrogen this hydrogen and this hydrogen
and what I said is this is stabilized so
an electron here can actually jump over
here and then so if this electron jumps
over here the double bond is now over
there if that goes over there like that
the double bond is now over here now
this guy now this guy lost this electron
and it would have a positive charge and
then that is resonance stabilized it can
either go back to this guy or or this
electron over here can jump over there
so let me redraw the whole thing over
again redraw the whole thing let me draw
all the hydrogen's so this right here
you have the e and the hydrogen you have
a hydrogen here hydrogen here hydrogen
here hydrogen here and normally you
don't worry about the hydrogen's but one
of the hydrogens is going to be nabbed
later on in this in this mechanism so I
want to draw the hydrogen's so you know
that they are there but as I said this
is resonance stabilized if if this
electron right here jumps over there
then this double bond is now this double
bond and now this guy over here lost an
electron so it would have
positive charge and again once you had
this double bond up here this double
bond up there's that double bond so we
can go back and forth between these the
electrons are just swishing around the
ring so it's not going to be maybe as
great as the situation that we had when
we had a nice benzene ring that was
completely aromatic the electrons could
just go around the p-orbitals round and
round the ring stabilized structure but
this is still a relatively stable carbo
cation because the electrons can move
around you can kind of view it as a
positive charge it gets dispersed
between this carbon this carbon and that
carbon over there now this as I said
this is still not a great situation it
wants to get the molecule wants to go
back to being aromatic wants to go to
that really stable state and the way it
can go back to that really stable status
somehow an electron can be added to this
thing and the way that electron can be
added to this thing is if we have some
base flying around if we have some base
flying around and that base NAB's
this proton this proton right here
that's on the same carbon as where the
electrophile is attached so this base
NAB's a proton so it just snaps the
hydrogen nucleus then that electron that
the hydrogen had that electron let me do
that in a different color i reused that
electron that the hydrogen had right
over there could then be returned to
this carbon up there and maybe that
makes it a little confusing when I cross
lines I can be returned to that carbon
right there so what would it look like
after that after that it would look like
this so let me draw my so if that
happened we drew it in yellow we have
our six carbon ring six carbon ring let
me draw all the hydrogen's so what did I
do that in it looks like a slightly
green color I did that in so I have all
the hydrogen's on that ring all of the
hydrogen's now have to be careful this
hydrogen right there just the nucleus of
it got nabbed by this base so that
hydrogen has now been nabbed by the base
if you view this electron right here has
now been given to this hydrogen so that
electron has now been given to this
hydrogen and then the other electron in
the pair is still at the base the other
electron is still with the base so now
this is the conjugate acid of the base
it has gained a proton and on this
carbon right here we just have what was
the electrophile
we just have what was the electrophile
and I'll do the same colors just to make
it clear what was the electrophile right
over there this bond this bond is or
this bond is this bond and then finally
we had an all color-coded here just made
clear we had this double bond here which
is this double bond right over here we
had this double bond we had this double
bond which is that double bond there and
this electron and was this electron gets
returned to this top carbon right here
so that electron that electron let me
make it very very clear so the bond and
that electron are returned to that top
carbon so that we have the bond and that
electron returned to that top carbon
that top carbon is now is now going to
be neutral and once again we are
resonance stabilized on one thing I
forgot just to make the charge
stabilized maybe this base had a
negative charge to begin with didn't
have to but if this base did have a
negative charge to begin with it now
gave an electron it gave an electron to
the hydrogen so it is now neutral and
this should make sense because before we
had a plus charge and a negative charge
and then when everything reacted
everything is neutral again the total
net charge is zero but this is the
electrophilic aromatic substitution we
substituted we substituted one of the
hydrogen's we substituted this hydrogen
right here with this electrophile or
what was previously the electrophile but
then once it got an electron we just
it's just kind of a group that is now on
the benzene ring and by going through
this little convoluted process we
finally got to another aromatic molecule
that now had this
that now that has this group on it in
the next video I'll show you this with
particular examples of electro files and
bases